typical day on set
typical day on set um we wake up from
having
not really slept
um we get out of our sleeping bags
because we're sleeping on the floor of a
crappy house
in the living room because there are no
bedrooms for us or bedroom
and thomas proceeds to step on my
glasses
breaking them apart
and
i couldn't wear contacts because it was
the desert and there were
dust storms every day and it was super
dry so
then he went into the kitchen and cried
into a bowl of cereal
and i tried not to lose my mind because
i really can't see without my glasses
but i'm and
um then the day just got worse from
there pretty much that was in the
beginning and there was a windstorm
so
we had to redo our schedule
as we went and move all our exterior
day shoots to
turn around our schedule so we were
shooting interiors
and then we
get into the chaos of production in
which for 12 to 14 hours nothing stops
pretty much uh
for a 17-day shoot i think we did a
pretty good job of sticking to 12 this
hour day yes
so we're on a tight schedule with actors
because they were sag and we didn't want
to mess with it too much so
but we worked i mean everyone worked
really hard we had a really small crew
yeah like really small and i felt very
strongly that i got i got really sick
for one day so it wasn't too but every
other day i was like i'm gonna be the
first one working in the last one
working because
i don't want anyone else to feel like
we're not doing it together
i think it also creates a better morale
on set if you do that if you're like if
you're packing stuff up at the end of
the day
if i don't have to be scheduling or
meeting with an actor or something i'm
packing stuff up with you that was but
it really did never i mean it never
ended no never ended for not for us for
our producer for our line producer
i mean the four of us
our ide for the tp i mean the dp was you
know transferring cards till you know
whatever o'clock in the morning and our
a.d was frantically trying to schedule
with us because we had to make a new
schedule you know on the fly yeah
um we had like this great shooting
schedule that made so much sense and we
were so proud of it and it got totally
scrapped you know on the first day
because of the windstorm
and then we just kind of
rolled with it this is a very scattered
answer sorry well can we talk about the
snakes and spiders oh yeah so the house
that we were staying in the crew house
um
my dear parents
came out and
cooked for us
which they had no idea what they were
getting into god bless them but um they
were going i may have cried into my
cereal but rebecca's dad i think cried
like every day for a week called my
brother in tears saying i didn't know it
was going to be like that
i mean granted they were working with a
kitchen that didn't actually have the
stove didn't work
and they were you know cooking in like
30 minutes from the nearest grocery
store and like that grocery store was
really bad and had to prepare the food
and then drive it 15 minutes
and set up a table on top of a pool
table and serve lunch and then
break it all down before we started
shooting again anyway yeah they were in
their own private house
which they were not telling us about and
they walked outside of the kitchen one
day and there was this snake coiled you
know a big snake coiled outside on the
patio
and my mom even though she has grown up
in los angeles and knows what snakes are
like has lived in the desert her whole
life
was like oh it's a fake snake it's a toy
snake because it's not plastic it's made
out of plastic why isn't it moving i'm
going to poke it with a stick just to
make sure it's fixed just to make sure i
think it's a plastic steak but in order
to make sure i'm gonna poke it with this
stick
then she gets my dad into the mix
they're both standing there poking this
snake yeah with a stick
turns out the snake was very real
nine there was another step
the snake started rattling oh yeah
to which they responded it's a battery
operated toy snake they're like it must
have a battery that it's that it's
making this rattle so it's like clearly
they were you know they had lost their
minds they had lost they were desert
crazy yeah luckily they did not get
bitten by the giant rattlesnake yeah it
was real the end of the story is that it
was real it did not bite them thank god
and but it camped outside of the house
for two days and so we'd get home after
like a 14-hour day and it would just be
like lying in front of the front door
and we'd all be like oh god
still here yeah
is that a real term desert crazy i mean
do you
go into a psychosis so here's the thing
about the desert we were always like oh
the desert's so great we go out there
every year for new year's and we like
we're real desert people yeah we hang
out
after spending a month in the desert you
understand why people aren't supposed to
live there yeah why everyone's crazy do
who live there are insane yeah they're
all insane and also it's very different
to like vacation there and versus trying
to actually do something in the desert
right like when you are at the mercy of
the elements
it is a brutal place even at the best of
times it's brutal yeah it's just
inhospitable yeah so hot in the day and
so cold at night
and so dry i mean everyone by the end of
the shoot just looked like they were 100
years old artist was like dying because
all of like every all the actors skin
was so dry yeah you know everyone was
like peeling they got sunburned and it
was just
poor ashland yeah she did a great job